انقلاب سريع بدا في رايك بالمقاسي رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي تجاه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه تراجع عن تعليقته
السابقه والذي كان قد صرح بعدم ثقته بقوه
ترامب لكنه الان يراه اقوى مما كان عليه
عام 2016 بحسب حديثه لموقع
السبب الوحيد الذي يجعل بايدن يستخدم
حكومته الفيدراليه لملاحقه الرئيس ترامب
هو انه اقوى خصم سياسي لبيض كما تظهر
استطلاعات الراي
تصريحات ماكارتي الجديده تزمنت مع نتائج
الاستطلاع الراي اجرتهم منظمه مورنينج
كونسل للابحاث والتي اظهرت تقدم ترامب على
منافسه بايدن ب 30 نقاط مئويه
من القضايا القانونيه المرفوعه عليه اشار
الى ان وسائل الاعلام تحاول زرع الفتنه
بين ترامب والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
لكن قبل يوم واحد فقط كان ماكورتي يتحدث
عن عدم يقينه حول قوه ترامب لشبكه سي ان
بي سي وبالرغم من اعتقاده انه يمكن ان
يفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الا انه عول
على ضعف بايدن لا قوه خصمه ما اثر غضب
مستشاري ترامب اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات